[Music]
[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life where we sit
through philosophy to find practical
advice that you can use in your everyday
life hi i'm dan hayes and i'm joined by
my co-host dr greg zadler and today
we're talking about
the trolley problem or rather trolley
problems in the plural
and we brought this topic up previously
in episode 22 which focused on thought
experiments we talked about several
different types of thought experiments
the trolley problem being one of them so
now we're going to do a deeper dive
and the first thing that we have to talk
about is well what is the trolley
problem because i think a lot of people
assume that they know exactly what it is
and this is not helped by popular
culture for example the good place where
they you know tell you what the trolley
problem with like and i actually put
capital t capital h capital e
in our show notes um
it's not actually the single unique
trolley problem nor the even
original one
so you know we could think about where
do people get this idea from partly it's
from pop culture and we're going to talk
a lot about that
and if you've ever had a intro to
philosophy or an ethics class
you probably ran into the trolley
problem as a matter of fact teaching
those classes
i often have students bring up trolley
problems to me even if i don't bring
them up myself right so there's a lot
that we
um
want to cover in this uh dan do you want
to talk about the the
the conception of the trolley problem
that is out there now the
it's not the original one but it's the
what should we call it the predominant
one
predominant one this predominant one on
is that there is a
on
a trolley which is going down track and
it's going down an incline and the
brakes fail
and
uh also the conductor is also
um
failed in that uh he is like passed out
and you happen to be standing by
on the side and there is a switch that
will change the trolley from the current
track to another track the problem is
that the current track if you do nothing
you stand by and you know by act of a
mission do nothing the trolley goes down
and
hits and kills five people who just
happen to be tied to the track
um
or you know i guess you could also be
standard that are standing in front of
the track and they're so engrossed in
their work that you know they uh don't
see the trolley coming
um and if you switch the track then it
will uh switch to an adjacent track in
which only one person will be hit and
killed by the trolley
and
you know one of the biggest things with
these types of thought experiments is
that they are like really
narrowly defined in order to try to
elicit a specific
conversation
from the like the people that are
talking about them and you know as greg
and i both know that whenever you're in
one of these especially intro ethics
classes
people tried to wriggle out of this yeah
any way possible oh well what if i had
like a boulder or like you know i could
just push it or you know they'd find any
way to try to not actually have to deal
with the dilemma that is faced but um
that's the whole point of these and
that's not just a problem with the
trolley problem it's any sort of thought
experiment there's something about human
nature that that's like i want to screw
with this i want to
as dan said try to wriggle my way out of
the confines and it's it's a different
thought experiment if you start adding
in all sorts of provisos and and you
know so like if you have 10 tracks now
it's not the original
well it's not even still the original
trolley problem but it's it's a it's a
less original trolley problem if indeed
still a trolley problem
um
and part of what we're getting the point
here is to present a particular moral
dilemma yeah and
a lot of times they're like well what is
some way that i can make it so
no one there is no dilemma at all and
now you've gotten away from the whole
point of having the conversation in the
first place right you know and it's sort
of like that game that there was even a
whole book out uh along these lines
almost like mad libs were when we were
younger
would you rather right would you rather
do a or would you rather do b and it's a
moral dilemma and there's some sort of
ethical problem it's not just would you
rather eat worms or
i don't know swallow slugs or something
like that where it's just gross it it
has to do with
key ideas of ethics like
rights or
harms and benefits or duties or or
things like that
i did want to go ahead would you rather
fight
um a hundred duck-sized elephants or one
elf and size duck yeah
and then you know somebody's gonna say
well i
i give the duck a a cracker and now it
likes me and now i'm no longer in the
problem
right so one of the things that i came
across in doing a little bit of
show research for this was that
even dictionaries get the trolley
problem
as i put it here adorkably wrong like
the merriam-webster online dictionary
frames it as a matter of utilitarianism
which is a word
versus
deontologicalism which is not a word
which you know in a dictionary using a
word that's not a word that seems to be
a bit of a a problem so there's
something about this that kind of gets
people
deranged
and
you know
there there is an original trolley
problem
which we could now this is an open topic
should we call this the you know capital
t
trolley problem because it's the
original one it's something quite
different in which there's a trolley
going down the tracks like like dan just
talked about forcing you to choose
between killing five or killing one
but that's only part of the problem and
we find this articulated in an article
in the 1960s by the great philosopher
philippa foote and then that's given
fuller scope and interesting variants by
judith jarvis thompson who's writing
mostly in legal journals
but she's also an important philosopher
so we're going to talk about a lot of
different things in this episode we're
going to do some intellectual history
first and then we're going to talk about
some of the questions this this raises
and then how this turned into
memes what kind of memes you know these
aren't actually richard dawkins memes
uh even his notion of meme didn't hold
still
and we're going to talk about a lot of
the applications that people make of
this it's not all just
conundrums in ethics classes or funny
episodes on the good place or or things
like that
so felipa foote right she's a major uh
moral philosopher of the 20th century
known for a lot of stuff besides the
trolley problem but this is something
quite important
um and the first so this is where the
first trolley problem comes from she's
not particularly interested in trolleys
for their own sake
it's called the problem of abortion and
the doctrine of the double effect and so
she's using these cases to try to think
about
you know real life situations with
abortion
and um
she brings up the trolley as just one
interesting idea we and we should talk
very quickly about double effect dan and
i were
kicking around how deep we should go
into this i think just one line from her
thing is probably
enough for for illuminating it and we
can do a whole episode on this if people
are really interested so if you are then
you know maybe
write us or make some comments
she says the doctrine of double effect
is based on a distinction between what a
man foresees as a result of his
voluntary action and what in the strict
sense
he intends and so that's that's the core
of the idea there's a difference between
foreseeing that your actions are going
to lead to something and actually
intending it so you know when you for
example
um
say something to somebody that needs to
be said
you can foresee it's probably going to
hurt their feelings
but that's not what you're actually
intending to do you might be intending
to keep them from
blowing their life savings in a get rich
quick scheme right and so you know we
want to be able to make that kind of
distinction and that's that's what she
was trying to aim at in this
this entire set of
problems that she brought forward some
of which involve trolleys
go ahead you're gonna
it goes further into this of like
both the
the act uh and what the intention of the
act is
um
if that
uh
direct intention is supposed to be good
or bad yeah but also being aware of
what's any of these indirect results of
these could be in themselves them
bad and so you know if you are once
again aiming for
some good thing even though you know
that there's some bad thing that is
going to happen
um
that is
still in itself
good
um yeah the goodness is not the goodness
of the good part is not eliminated you
might say by the
the accompanying
or
foreseeing badness
yeah so for example
like because this is talking like about
abortion yeah they're talking about a
couple different examples of this um
under this doctrine it is saying that if
you're going to perform something that
is
on directly causing the death of the
child
um even if it is to protect the the
mother um that would still be a bad
because that is the the direct intention
um but if you're doing something that um
is to save the
life of the
mother but indirectly causes
the death of the child that is a good
thing so for example this be if they had
a cyst
on or a a cancerous tumor on
their
reproductive organs that had to be
removed through a hysterectomy yeah this
is
still a good thing even though the
uh ancillary effect is the definition
you know another another medical ethics
case like that comes up when you have um
multiple children in gestation
and one of them is probably not going to
make it and they wind up being
you know a drain upon or a threat to the
mother and the other
children i mean that's a very difficult
situation but the doctrine of double
effect allows you to say
in order to save the life of
you know these others and you could do
it in kind of a utilitarian way where
you're trying to maximize benefit
minimize harm
um you can you can do that so
yeah and foot was very interested in
these kinds of uh cases um which were
you know
1967 this was becoming
quite an issue in the britain and
america of her time
and it might be again yeah
so let's let's come back to her article
so
um she she talks about like the case of
a judge who would
execute somebody or find you know find
subject somebody to to execution in
order to
assuage a mob that would otherwise hurt
people or kill other people and then she
brings up the trolley and she says to
make the parallel
as close as possible it may be supposed
that he is the driver of a runaway tram
notice a tram not trolley which he can
only steer from one narrow track onto
another five men are working on one
track and one man and the other anyone
on the track he enters is bound to be
killed now notice there's no bystander
at the switch
it's the guy running the trolley itself
who has to make the decision
and the actual problem the way that she
frames it is like this
the question is why we would say without
hesitation that the driver should steer
for the less occupied track
while most of us would be appalled at
the idea that the innocent man
would be framed by the judge from mob
justice
and then she brings up another case to
make this even
another set of cases to make this even
more clear
we are about to give a patient who needs
it to save his life a massive dose of a
certain drug in short supply they arrive
however five other patients each of whom
could be saved by one-fifth of that dose
we say with regret that we cannot spare
our whole supply of the drug for a
single patient we feel bound to let one
man die rather than many if that is our
only choice so that's like the trolley
problem right with the trolley problem
it's going down the track to hit
somebody
in this case with the drugs people are
going to die
the question is how you're going to
apportion
the death that's that's going to take
place and then she says
why then do we not feel justified in
killing people in the interests of
cancer research because you know if
you're going to follow this kind of like
utilitarian reasoning
well maybe it's okay to to kill one
person instead of you know letting
others
uh die in their place
or to obtain here here we're starting to
get to the the one that's going to
become the hospital or surgeon example
why can we not
take spare parts for grafting onto those
who need them or we could suppose
similarly that several dangerously ill
people can be saved
only if we kill a certain individual and
make a serum from his dead body now
foot thinks that those cases are
different so on the one hand we have
trolley problems
and you know rationing drugs or it could
be rationing
covet vaccines or rationing antibiotics
or anything else that we want
on the other side we have cases where we
actively kill somebody
in order to save
five other people by means of
something you know coming from from
their body
and she wants to say why are these
different from each other because she
thinks
that you and me and everybody else will
naturally say well it's it's fine to
change the course of the trolley which
turns out not everybody is cool with
right and we're also all going to say no
no you can't for example
take an innocent person and harvest
their five you know
organs from you know from their body to
save five people who who need organs um
so go ahead
uh so she proposes another like
accesses for us to look at this through
a different way another uh you know a
prism and to look at both through yeah
acts of omission and commission but also
through these ideas of positive and
negative rights which you know positive
rights
result in positive duties and so that
you know would result in a right to be
positively benefited by another
and negative rights lead to negative
duties which leads to the right not to
be harmed yeah and you can think about
go ahead
and so especially for like the the
trolley problem you know that we're
we're standing on the side of the track
versus
philippa's
version of the trolley problem where you
are in the conductor
see now you have two different um ideas
of what your rights are uh as the actual
conductor you have a positive right to
try to you know to try uh to actually
steer the train in a way that reduces
you know
the loss of life whereas if you're just
a bystander you never had that positive
duty enforced upon you because you were
not in the position of actually being
the trained driver
you know she doesn't actually consider
the bystander at the switch it's that
that's later with you you're directly
she's yeah this is
um but she does
uh specifically bring up these these
positive negative rights maybe that's
better uh example exemplified in uh when
she was talking about um
doing the uh the difference between
um
that and the
uh
[Music]
framing a innocent person in order to
start stop and mob
yeah who's who are gonna kill five
other people
and so
yeah she sees these cases as
qualitatively different from each other
and and the real interesting
question here is i mean we there's
actually several because we can say well
do people really view things the way
that that she does we're going to talk
about that a little bit later when we
get to the psychology and the
experiments as it turns out no
but she says okay assume that people
actually do see these as different from
each other
why are they different from each other
let's provide a
philosophical explanation because a lot
of people can have a gut sense that oh
yeah these are different i would decide
this one differently than this one
but articulating it that's a bit
difficult to do
so this leads us to judith thompson
who is looking at it from a legal
perspective and she has a couple
different articles
one of which is called killing letting
die in the trolley problem and then she
has one that's just called the trolley
problem and this is the one that i
usually teach in my classes
and she is the one who's responsible for
taking foot's cases and then adding
variants of her own to the mix and
labeling them too you know that that's
important in philosophy you gotta have a
nice catchy title
and so she coins the
um
the real
iconic contemporary trolley problem
which is bystander at the switch
and she asks
why is it that the trolley driver can
turn his trolley
though the surgeon may not remove the
young man's lungs kidneys and heart in
both cases one will die if the agent
acts but five will live who otherwise
would die which is a net saving of four
lives what difference in the other facts
of these cases explains the moral
difference between them
and you know it's by manipulating the
scenario that you can you can get to
what what the difference is and she goes
she goes through kind of a cool
um maybe it's this no it's not that
a sequence of proposals before she
finally settles on
how it becomes
um
okay to do one but not the other and she
proposes a lot of cool um
new new cases the bystander the switch
the one that dan narrated at the start
you're you're the one who actually
controls which way the runaway trolley
goes whether you flip a switch or not
now flipping a switch is a positive
action
letting the trolley run over people oh
you didn't you didn't make the scenario
right and then there's fat man where
instead of having a switch you're on a
bridge and you could push a fan man off
that bridge
and he would stop the trolley
that's a bit different she thinks that
that's different than flipping a switch
mafia guys on the track is another one
what if the five guys were actually
mafiosos
and you would be you know increasing the
net
happiness of the world by letting the
trolley run over them should you should
you not flip the switch then should you
allow them to get hit then there's
another one
and this is really quite contrived a
mayor makes a promise
where
there's five workmen on the track and
then there's a length of track where
there's a guy
eating and he's eating there precisely
because the mayor has told them that
there will never be a trolley going down
that track so the mayor has made a
promise to this guy and the mayor is the
one who has to
decide
do these change
how we should
answer the question i mean and i think
with the mafia one i mean
i'll tell you my take and then i want to
hear what your take is on this
definitely we we let the trolley run
over the five guys in that case and
because we don't you know the one guy um
he's
just sort of neutral
what what would you do
so like
the immediate answer seems to be similar
to yours but then i'm like okay
they're human beings after all
well more along the lines of what are
the consequences like how how far away
can we talk take these consequences okay
and so we've got immediate consequences
you have five mafiosis died
on say they're like big time on in the
mafia and now you have a power vacuum
and now you've then started off a a new
whole center award yeah okay
between either buying factions of the
mafia or two different uh zoo criminal
organizations and does that actually
cause more
uh
death and destruction by killing off
these five because they were you know
at least maintaining order in their the
criminal enterprise
uh i don't i it's really hard in that
regard because
you know if you're just gonna conti
contain it to that exact moment yeah
yeah um but
once you you go a year down the road
it's really hard to see the the effects
that are going to happen yeah it becomes
difficult to predict all the myriad
different new timelines that it
generates you could say
yeah but that's also true for any of
these particular
uh scenarios you don't know
what you don't know going down
the track of these different uh
potential histories
that's quite true
and you know and she brings in all sorts
of other cool variants i mean if you
haven't read the article we'll put links
to where you can find these in the show
notes because they're well worth
checking out
um she's got some cool cases about
doctors and patients in hospitals i
mentioned one where so i'll narrate it
this this guy
this guy's a doctor he's got five
patients i think e two of them need lung
transplants one needs a heart transplant
two
two needs liver one one need to harvest
kid i think no two two need kidneys
kidneys yeah yeah yeah and so you know
they're they're you know how it is with
donor lists uh they're just not gonna
get it and they're all gonna die that
day and income's a healthy guy for his
checkup or maybe a flu shot or whatever
it's gonna be
nothing fatal and the doctor says to him
listen i got a conundrum here
i got these five patients they're all
gonna die you could really make a
contribution here by letting me cut up
your organs now you would die in the
process
and
you know but he would be really
benefiting humankind and then the guy
says no i'm gonna pass on that um i kind
of like to live and then the doctor says
oh okay and then he like shoots him up
with a drug or hits him over the head
whatever it's gonna be and he harvests
his organs anyway
and he saves those five lives well
that's
a net gain of five over one isn't it and
yet we should see this as morally
repugnant and then she goes into all
sorts of other like interesting things
well what if the doctor is actually
responsible for these five people having
organ failure because he he gave them a
drug a year ago that caused these organ
failures now he's just kind of setting
things right by
taking this poor guy off the street and
killing him and you know he is doing
something objectively evil and wrong but
he's also you know kind of balancing
things out from his previous evil
actions how should we you know
think about that one is is what she
says and there's there's other
interesting things about you know gas is
in a hospital that would kill patients
being diverted and
you know you can you can read these for
yourself it's quite ingenious the things
that she comes up with um the other
thing that i do want to mention
you know this starts getting us into the
pop culture land
she talks about the villains who create
this these situations who tied the
people down to the track right right
yeah
yeah i mean it's sort of it's sort of
like when um i forget which movie it was
maybe you know dan where batman
is facing off against i think heath
ledger's joker and like there's people
on one end of town that he can save
people on which which one was that do
you remember that's um
oh
it's one of the dark knight right the
dark knight and that's what the joker
has
no it's the second one it's batman
begins and then the dark knight is the
second of the nolan
trilogy
um and so we have harvey dent um
in one area and then uh rachel
bruce
wayne's love interest in the other
um and they have
him
um
what
at the police station and you know
well there's a number of different
things you have this dilemma decision
and another thing to hold the whole
thing is that like batman is like
um basically trying to torture the joker
out of telling him like what's going on
and where i can go and save these people
and so there's a whole extra dilemma of
like should he be doing that even though
it's going to result in like this
benefit at the end
um yeah
but what was that now the question
especially is like you
it's also a flip because
um he does tell them where they are
um
but he he flips where the actual
locations are and so he's giving him bad
information even though it is true in
one sense he gives the location but not
the but flips the who's where
showing that he is truly a villain yeah
now
now um not foot but but thompson has a
really weird consideration here and when
i when i read this piece this is one of
the places where i'm like yeah i don't
know what she's actually doing with this
it's the idea is that you should not act
in such a way
as to improve the moral record as she
calls it of a villain
by choosing in such a way that the the
threat the villain imposes doesn't
actually get enacted against the five
for me i think that doesn't
you shouldn't worry about that but she
seems really quite concerned about that
did you have any ideas about about this
passage where she's
saying you shouldn't you know improve
the record of of bad people
it that doesn't
quite gel with me either like
it's it's hit the bad person's action
um
and and i can try to mitigate the damage
that this bad person is doing but it
shouldn't be for the benefit of this
villain that's just to try to have a
better outcome
yeah
i mean maybe maybe with some of these
articles
it doesn't make that much sense to buy
into everything that they say
um and and in order to get to the other
stuff because we're already getting a
little bit long with this i'll just
mention part of her solution she talks
about
it
what she calls a distributive exemption
for rights so when when you're turning
the trolley onto the track and running
over the one person you're violating
their right to life right and she says
that we can have an in we can allow an
intervention into the world to get an
object that already threatens death
to those many instead threaten death to
these few
but only by acts that are not themselves
gross impingements on the few so you
can't use means that in infringe
stringent rights of the few in order to
get their distributive intention carried
out and that's rather abstract the idea
is that you can in fact divert
a danger that's going to kill many more
people onto a danger on to just a few
people so you know she talks about
avalanches as an example right if you
can put one person in the in the course
of the avalanche rather than 100 it's
okay to do that um and
in that sort of case you're allowed to
violate their rights you're not allowed
to do it in other cases like the poor
guy who walks into the hospital right
right
and
and i would throw in like there's also
like
role-based rights or role-based duties
here
i'm pulling in from
a different set of moral axioms yeah the
look at the hippocratic oath as a doctor
good example the first
the first duty is to do no harm
and you know obviously uh intentionally
killing one person in order to save the
others is violating that original duty
for the doctor yeah and and i think we
can come up with similar
role i mean we could talk about like
parents and children maybe you know
and this is where it gets really tricky
what if it's
diverting the trolley
you know from the five people who you
don't know
onto a track where your child is
i think a lot of parents would probably
say
sorry but i'm
[Music]
gonna let it run you know
what do we make of that you know
um
so this is a good place to talk about
how we get from
the original stuff to
the trolley problem that we all know and
love and fear and argue about
incessantly
well
quickly i would just want to add one
more like duty
so the the trolley conductor in
philippa's
original
version of this
um has two positive duties
um one not to
hit the one person and another duty not
to hit the fly person yeah and so you
have
two
equal duties um or at least equal
category of duty and then you can just
quantify the
the amount of that whereas um when we're
talking about the bystander uh you have
removed that positive duty
yeah the bystander the switch is
different and this is why
this is why i think it becomes the
trolley problem
so
it gets reframed generally in terms of
is it okay to flip the switch or not and
that gets framed in terms of moral
theories
so on the one side if you do flip the
switch that's usually taken as
representative of what we call
consequentialist or even utilitarian
thinking where you're saying i need to
minimize the harm or maximize benefits i
need to like have the better outcomes
and then there's deontological moral
theories and these could be
that of a manual cont not using humanity
as a means it could be rights spaced it
could be
you know other things and those
typically say don't flip the switch
and the distinction that gets made there
is if i flip the switch i'm doing
something
whereas if i don't flip the switch even
though i could have i'm not actually
doing something to those five people i'm
just letting things happen
as they they go now i'm i'm kind of
curious
if we frame it only like that do you
flip the switch or not dan
oh um i flipped the switch to one all
the time me too
uh now does that mean that we're
utilitarians
or
because that's the way a lot of people
take it you're either utilitarian or
you're a deontologist
well like how do you i'm definitely
a little bit of both
you know i guess
um
in
i
ah sorry um
this is the whole point of this being a
dilemma because it is yeah um
is trying to put you in a position
um and and i guess one of the
kind of guiding lights for my personal
morality is that if i see something that
is right to do
and i it's costing me nothing to do it
then i should be doing that and
under the
uh the purely
um you know i don't know who these
there's just five versus one um under
that category organization of this
particular problem um
then yeah i put the switch
for me i'm you know i'm basically a
virtue ethicist and
a lot of people would take that as well
you can't be utilitarian in any way then
and i kind of think no there's actually
a lot of cases where you're going to
where the right thing to do is to to
choose the utilitarian
um solution to something you know
robert audi actually has a really
excellent article on this he's a
contemporary virtue ethicist
but he says that
virtue ethics and even deontological
ethics ought to use cost-benefit
analyses
when it makes sense to do so so i think
this is one of those cases where
it's almost a no-brainer you you know
one versus five i'm i'm gonna take the
the saving the five you know
right
now the there's this becomes what we
call trolleology it's a new term
and um frank bosman wrote something
interesting about this he says the rise
of trolleology
resulted in the trolley problem leaving
the exclusive realm of academic
philosophy for the complex world of
popular culture where it gained fame for
the masses but lost some of its original
philosophical finesse
what do you think did it lose some of
its philosophical finesse or did it gain
some in the process
it definitely
gain some silly
things but like
i'm a firm believer that silliness can
lead to some actually interesting and
deeper
philosophical thoughts you know uh
yeah i mean the
yeah there there are a lot of other
funny thought experiments right
and
um the silliness that you're talking
about i mean we we've referenced the
good place
i don't know if the trial i'm sure the
trolley problem comes up in some other
essentially sitcoms
or i don't know if maybe the good place
isn't a sitcom as such but it's
definitely a comedy
um
so
sure
you know i i i think
and it there is some silliness involved
in it
um
and this is kind of interesting too a
lot of people like i'm not a fan of the
good place because when i when i've
watched the few episodes of it i watched
i found that the philosophy was a little
bit too uh
too reductive and and i i found the
people a little bit you know it kind of
flip in the way that like the people who
always want to like they find out that
you're into philosophy and they're like
oh i've seen some monty python sketches
and you're like yeah that was funny like
30 years ago but
after the 20th time hearing the
philosopher's song i'm kind of over it
you know the good place for me was was
always kind of like that i know they
have a philosopher on staff but that
doesn't necessarily make it great but on
the other hand it is bringing it
bringing these ideas to
not thousands but
millions
of people who otherwise would not have
encountered them so maybe there's a good
you know utilitarian case there for
these kinds of shows uh being the way in
which we
teach people philosophy
i i kind of think of it as
yo a a really
kind of dumbed down uh
intro philosophy of course yeah at least
for the first season or two then it gets
into
um
gets into a little bit more
like the first season specifically that
show is very much like hey let's like
talk about like some
high level ideas here
and and if you look at it as just a
popularization of ideas
that are a road that will lead to
potentially greater understanding yeah
then great i think it's useful in that
case if we're talking about it being
um actually good deep philosophy
i don't think it really gets there until
the last season
okay but because the last season is
basically
the um
oh
the the head
philosophy on philosopher on staff is
basically his like dissertation and book
oh okay trying to be realized as you
were talking about it i kind of thought
so the good place is sort of like the
equivalent of the and i'm putting this
with air quotes the cool
professor
who all the students like but gives them
kind of like watered-down stuff and he
gets the great evaluations because he's
joking around all the time in class but
he never really goes that deeply into
the material and then 10 years later
when you're at a party and you quote
something that he told you and people
are like no that's that's wrong
you feel kind of like a like a fool for
having been taken in but you didn't know
any better because you you know he was
your professor so
right
uh
and we see this in other places where
there's popularization of
um certain things for
example
is ryan holiday in the oh stoicism yeah
yeah which you know
he's got some interesting stuff but i
wouldn't call most of it deep i'm in it
but it's brought a lot of people into
uh at least reading some of the more
deep stuff that you can actually find in
stoicism yeah i guess kudos to him for
that particular
achievement you know and i think the the
response that we could have as people
who like have progressed further and
want other people to progress further
is it's great when it's the gateway drug
but it's bad when that's all people are
going to be
stopping with if if people take it as
like this is what stoicism is what ryan
holliday is teaching rather than we'll
pick another figure uh
rather than what donald robertson or
chris gill is teaching
then we've got a problem right and so
with the trolley problem
maybe we want to say something similar
we we would like people to
go deeper into it than just what these
pop culture things are although the rest
of the show we're gonna basically be
talking about pop culture so
who are we to cast stones right
i mean do you do you want to talk about
some of the uh psychological stuff we
have enough time for that you think
probably um
this um
experiment i put in here that and and we
could also
talk about the self-driving car issues
but yeah tell us about this experiment
that that okay so in 2014
um natalie gold andrew m coleman and
brody d pulford did a
study in
untitled cultural differences in
response to real life and hypothetical
trolley problems
and
just as we're talking about like the
differences in why certain people
might choose one thing over the other on
their site their idea was there is there
potentially a difference based on the
cultural milieu that people grow up in
in how they respond to this particular
problem and so they had a
couple of experiments with different
formulations of the trolley problem some
that are more just financial based but
some are that are actually you know
straight up the trolley problem okay um
with about 200 people uh in it and the
major groups were a contingent of a
british people in a contingent of
chinese and they found that there was a
statistically different uh significantly
sorry a statistically significant
difference in the response rates to
um flipping the switch or not
of which the
chinese in comparison to the british
were
regularly
less likely to hit the switch
and a lot of the participants that did
not choose to fit switch that were of
um specifically the chinese contingent
uh gave fate as
interesting a major contributor to
why they decided to think do this and so
i guess this is a little bit out of
um i guess partly um confucianism i'm
gonna hold that back and say i don't
know but apparently
um the idea that they they should not be
interfering in the way that things are
going to actually happen that to what
fate uh
do its uh course was a strong indicator
for why they would choose not to whereas
the british
were much less likely to believe in fate
and were more likely to
flip the switches
that's interesting and i i bet if we did
similar experiments we could find all
sorts of variations
not only between
like large-scale you know world cultures
but also
maybe along class lines or maybe
along uh gender lines or things like
that you know
another um
response from that is
the
uh older that you got the more likely
you were to flip the switch
wow so you know that's kind of
counterintuitive but
that's that's an interesting finding
i'll bring up just a very short thing
about another study that was carried out
um they looked at the buy you know
bystander at the switch you flip the
switch or you don't flip the switch and
the fat man where you actually have to
physically push the fat man off onto the
tracks thereby causing his death to stop
the trolley
and they they asked people who thought
that these were like one's okay the
other one's not okay
for justifications
and
they um classified the justifications
into sufficient justifications that were
ones that pointed out at least one
difference between the two cases
insufficient justifications where they
failed to do that so maybe saying that
you know five lives are more important
one than one but not explaining why
and then discount this is really
interesting discountable objections
which is kind of a code word for
crazy off the wall has nothing to do
with the case kind of objections you
know like a man's body cannot stop a
train i guess people trying to wiggle
out of the story and then they found out
that once you got rid of the
discountable
really out there objections only 30
percent of the remaining justifications
were sufficient justifications people
could partly articulate but not very
well
why they thought these were different
which is kind of a bad sign i mean if
you can't explain
why you should do the right thing
does that you know does that get in the
way of doing the right thing some of the
time probably so right especially if
there's more than one person
involved in the decision making
right you know and i this is basically
the way that most humans make decisions
as we
we have kind of this right instinct of
how
what is right and wrong and we just act
on those and or we talk with other
people but we're kind of you know
inarticulate and saying well what do you
what do you think what should we do you
know
yeah
and there's not like a basis from which
i'm building
a actual decision yeah but it's just
like well you know i was
raised up to you know not hit anyone or
not to push and so maybe that was like
one of those like
intrinsic thoughts in you that like well
i shouldn't be pushing this guy that
that violates a really you know basic
norm of society
um but we can't like exactly articulate
that when we're talking about this
particular thing yeah i mean if people
can't
like prioritize between i shouldn't push
people and i shouldn't push people into
into deadly you know uh jeopardy or
something like that we're in real
problems right
so
well let's talk about the the
self-driving cars thing because i think
this is kind of interesting
um you know
we're gonna see a lot of technology with
machines being called on to make
decisions and so mit created something
called the moral machine
not just a experiment but a whole set of
scenarios that you can find at
moral
moralmachine.net
and they were really interested in
situations where it got a little bit
more granular where it wasn't just you
know one versus five
they started saying well you gotta hit
somebody is it a woman or a man
young person old person you know and
then they even went to like lawful
pedestrians over jaywalkers is it okay
to you know is it okay to like
if somebody's where they're not supposed
to be is it better to kill them than to
kill somebody else or you know humans
over animals
there was another thing involved where a
self-driving car could swerve to kill
its passengers or
save them by hitting various groups of
pedestrians now who who who should
who should the car kill you know i mean
those of us there might be a little bit
of class envy here i mean those of us
who don't have a lot of money might say
well obviously if you're rich enough to
afford a self-driving car the car should
kill you you know rather than
endangering other people whose lives you
know are not quite as good as yours um i
doubt the driver
don't you know the people who have more
money or inherently better people
yeah well i mean that's the way they
definitely see it right so
and this is really interesting stuff
have you have you ever played around on
that site
yeah it's crazy like you get like a
woman in her child versus like two nuns
yeah it gets really uh uh specific
doesn't it
right and it'll add in like pets and
stuff and like it's just trying to like
it's trying to find that line but like
the same problem exists here that we
were kind of like talking about when i
was talking about this british versus
chinese the roles
well the role stuff too
oh rules but i've been talking about
specifically that like different
cultures might have different answers to
these things it's not like there's some
perfect line of sand that will suffice
for every single group
but and i assume that the most people
that are using the moral machine are uh
probably western and uh
fairly affluent because they're on this
website well they're my students because
i have them play around with it too and
we do ethics classes and we do and you
know what i do in the context of
utilitarianism
um like when we're in that unit i'm like
hey you should check this out and and
some of them do um
yeah it's kind of a an interesting
quandary right there's a really great uh
passage that that we we've got here too
from carl
uh ianagama
or sorry uh yeah
yagna man
uh boy i'm having trouble with
pronouncing things anyway he says even
if trolley problems were a realistic
concern for autonomous vehicles it's not
clear what if anything regulators
or companies developing these should do
about them the trolley problem is an
intensely debated thought experiment
precisely because there isn't a
consensus on what should be done so if
that's really the case
maybe this moral machine stuff is not
going to be as helpful as we'd like
right
and but interesting literally there's
this other um paper uh
trolled by the trolley problem on what
matters for ethical decision making and
automated vehicles oh right
by alex energy
miring and alexander
um
yes i'm not even going to try it starts
with them um you can find it for
yourself um
in which uh they they come through uh
at least in this paper too for kind of
competing solutions
either you try to find some perfectly
utilitarian valuation of all potential
deaths and choose the course that
results in the you know the highest
value of the living
um
which seems like a really difficult task
um especially on the fly and you're
going like 60 miles an hour it's like
how do you like
uh calculate the value um
the another one is like to try to find
the least undesirable choice is the best
choice
usually through just the amount of death
that is made um another one is you know
sidestep the utilitarian and move it to
a more intentions-based choice make a
decision based on saving lives knowing
that some death is going to happen
either way so we're like trying to just
uh
optimize for saving lives but
their final conclusion is
basically once again a sidestepping of
the trolley problem in which they say
okay
trolley problems are vanishingly small
um in the real world they can still
happen
but
instead of trying to solve the trolley
problems
limited resources to try to put
the vehicles in the situation in order
to reduce ever having to find a solution
to the trolley problem in the first
place
you know that reminds me of something
that aleister mcintyre points out
aleister mcintyre is a great
contemporary virtue ethicist and he's
got a paper on not on trolley problems
but on moral dilemmas and he says do
moral dilemmas really exist some people
say they don't and he says no they
really do exist there are some cases
where you have to choose between
two evils or two goods and it's really
difficult to choose between them
but he points out that whenever we
actually have a genuine moral dilemma
we have a real problem in the the
present but that's because something got
seriously screwed up in the past
somebody made bad decisions
along the way and now there's not much
we can do about that but this this um
sidestepping idea that you're
articulating here it's sort of like
saying in the future let's try to make
sure that there's less moral dilemmas
and i think that's that's a great idea
you know
right if we can do it like
yeah
i know have the cars drive slower um
yeah
that might happen build infrastructure
that helps to potentially reduce the the
chance of having pedestrians and cars
interacting the first place there's lots
of other things that we can do to reduce
these things to happen
and and that might be if we're talking
about how do we you know a kind of a
utilitarian sense save lives or have the
most good
maybe spending more time on that is what
will actually give us the best outcome
now we're gonna we're gonna talk very
briefly about
actual trolley problem memes
and you can just google trolley problem
memes and they'll come up we don't have
to try to tell you where to find them or
stuff like that but what you're saying
reminds me of one of the memes that we
selected actually one of the ones that
you picked out
where it's not a real trolley problem
there's a trolley there's a single track
and there's a whole bunch of people tied
to the track and it says you can stop
the trolley problem at any time but
doing so would disrupt the trolley
service causing the company to lose
profits right and so you can flip the
switch if you want the company that's
not paying you anything to lose profits
and there would definitely be some
americans who'd be like nope free
marketplace got it can't can't stop it
gotta let it go you know
um there's another one that's kind of
similar to that where it shows like the
trolley having run over a whole bunch of
people before and then there's a whole
bunch of people in front and it says is
it really fair to stop the trolley is
that fair to the people who were already
run over to not run over these these
other people and of course the
intelligent person's answer would be
yes let it let it stop the trolley you
know
but
i believe that one's called the boomer
trolley problem
oh
that because
i went through this so you have to go
through this i was like no let's just
fix the problem
yeah
you know i think i think i may have
brought this up in the past but
when i was in basic training you know
which which sucks
um there were you know there were people
who were like man when i have rank i'm
never going to treat my soldiers this
way and then there were some people who
are like i can't wait to make rank so i
can make somebody else suffer
you know
i
so i i love the one that you picked
that you particularly liked
so the veil of ignorance trolley problem
has
you don't know where you'll be in the
trolley problem it's a regular trolley
problem but you can either be
on in the end you're going to either be
one of the five guys you're going to be
one of the one guys stuck in the track
you'll be
uh
in the trolley itself or you can be the
one on the switch
and this is uh from the veil of
ignorance from
oh
shoot remind me um
john rawls yeah john rawls yes
ralsian
theory of justice
right um so you don't know where you're
going to be in the trolley problem
however you have the choice
uh to you have to choose a scenario in
advance regarding regarding personal
interest would you like to be
would you like to have the lever pulled
so you don't know if you're going to be
on the track or not
uh do you have the person pull the lever
or not
you know
if you just think about it in a
statistical way
you're most likely to be one of the five
tied to the track so i would say yes you
do want the lever pulled right right if
if you wind up being the person in the
trolley you don't care because you're
gonna you know run over people no matter
what the person at the switch
he's actually in this case he doesn't
have any responsibility he's just being
told what to do
right
he's got no agency yeah
yeah but i guess the whole point of the
veil of ignorance is that we all make a
decision together before we even go into
the situation so we all have
you know voted for
responsibility
yes so there is some agency even for the
guy who's pulling the switch even though
the decision was already made
that's true so there's one that came up
in mcsweeney's the uh internet comedy
site called the meta ethical problem and
this is the so i'm gonna read this and
then we might have time to do a little
actually we probably won't have that
much time yeah i'll just read it there's
an out of control trolley speeding
towards immanuel kant you have the
ability to pull a lever and change the
trolley's path so it hits jeremy bentham
instead jeremy bentham clutches the only
existing copy of kant's groundwork for
the metaphysics immorals kant holds the
only existing copy of bentham's the
principles of morals and legislation
both of them are shouting at you that
they have recently started to reconsider
their ethical stances these are the you
know utilitarian and deontologists the
big grand daddies of both of those
theories so this is just ingenious i
love this one oh yeah like
it just hits on so many perfect levels
and then the last one and they're both
reconsidering their ethical stances oh
yeah
and you know
it's getting you know the double whammy
right because
so if you save bentham he's got the
existing copy of kant's ground works for
the metaphysics and morals which then
you could read and you can see what kant
has to say about it so either way you
kind of save both of them don't you
except for
if uh
they're changing their stances they
might not tell you what they had
originally written because they no
longer hold to it all right
yeah yeah that's that's and they're
shouting at you that's that's great well
i i don't think we have time for any
more of them so why don't you lead us
out on a last final thought
so uh today we leave you with the words
of
kwame anthony apaya
being
deluged with trolley problems is one of
the professional hazards of modern moral
philosophy
[Music]
you